around 30% of our planet is covered in
trees trees are majestic help
biodiversity and can reduce climate
change but we're cutting them down at an
alarming rate since the start of human
civilization
it's estimated that we've cut down
almost half the trees on earth so what
would happen if all of us and that's all
seven point seven billion of us planted
a tree well there might be seven point
seven billion of us but it's estimated
there are currently over three trillion
trees on the planet seven point seven
billion more trees would be a valuable
step forward but we need to go further
to make a really substantial difference
to the environment but we could in fact
according to one estimate if we planted
1.2 trillion trees we'd cancel out a
decade's worth of co2 emissions by the
time the forests mature so that's more
like 160 trees per person trees take
carbon dioxide out of the air and
release oxygen making them a natural
source of carbon capture planting 1.2
trillion more trees to capture up to 100
Giga tons of co2 on top of the 400
gigatons captured by all our existing
trees trees planted near the equator can
be especially beneficial as they grow
much faster in the warm wet and humid
environment let's imagine that happened
and as little as 20 or 30 years entire
woodlands and forests would be
established and in a hundred years these
trees would grow and mature safeguarding
habitats that otherwise get cut down
we'd also see a rise in biodiversity
as trees get older and start to
decompose because they along with dead
trees offer a habitat to all kinds of
fungi and insects on top of this we
could see a positive impact to our
mental health our studies have shown
trees can lower stress and make people
happier in Japan they have a term for it
forest bathing but despite how much
trees offer us we're getting rid of them
at an alarming rate currently it's
estimated that 15 percent of all
greenhouse gas emissions are the result
of deforestation because when we cut
down trees they emit carbon instead of
absorbing it
and we're cutting down 15 billion trees
a year that's almost 500 trees a second
29,000 a minute 1.7 million an hour and
41 million a day
so although tree planting is a valuable
part of tackling climate change it won't
be effective unless we reduce the number
we cut down in the first place
and make big changes to the way we live
so if everyone on the planet planted a
single tree it would be a powerful
symbolic act and if we kept on planting
them and stopped cutting them down it
could go a long way to protecting and
safeguarding our world thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to receive notifications
for new videos see you again soon